so let me ask you who
who's the voice of reason right now who
can the american people trust to be like
all right this is actually what's
happening because you have people like
uh michael bury coming out and basically
saying he's the guy that called the big
short in 2008 right you know if you saw
the movie the big short christian bill
famously played him you have kiyosaki
who's i feel like is always calling for
some sort of reset yeah uh even patrick
bet david has brought this up you it
seems like you're indicating that
you know with the uh the yield curve the
potential research is coming just did a
video about that right about being
prepared major video exactly so i think
you you just listened to the to the bond
market because historically the bond
market is smart money the stock market's
dumb money
so you just look at the 10-year the
30-year i mean the the since the fed
raised rates by 75 basis points
initially the 10-year spiked up slightly
but now it's just gone down down down
look at the gold market going down oil
market going down well it's still very
high those are going down that tells you
that people the smart money is betting
that we're going to have a recession so
there are no certainties there are only
probabilities
but right now if i was someone with a
sizable portfolio i would be positioning
for taking advantage of asset prices
going lower in the future okay so let's
stop right there so
you know they always say buy the dip buy
the dip right you know so um
if you're an average american right
you're making 50 grand a year you maybe
you know you've got your head on you
know you got some investments you're
saving you've got some debt you're
trying to get rich on crypto you know
you hear this recession talk you got
some more guys like george gammon vane
saying hey you know prepare yourself for
this what tangible action steps can the
average american do
to really prepare for this because for
instance you know what they talk about
is you know obviously asset allocation
diversification you know the whole like
80 20 rule if you're 80 have 20
in
stocks 80 in bonds and if you're 20 have
20 in bonds 80 stocks it's kind of like
i always try to you know dummify
investing for for people that don't get
it and essentially it's like the younger
you are have more stocks the older you
are have more bonds but
that's just my uh dumbed-down approach
but like that's gonna make sense a
question for you too as well is uh why
do i i don't think i've asked you this
before why
did you think that the crypto market has
bottomed out or has falling out of it
right now
well
there's a rule that i learned from uh my
investment heroes a guy named jim rogers
and he says you always sell hysteria
and buy panic yeah so you'll notice when
when bitcoin
got over
45 000 you know 50 000 60 000 you saw
hysteria everywhere i mean just go on
twitter you know if you were to even
mention
that there might not be a one hundred
percent probability that bitcoin was
going to a million dollars a hundred
thousand they're saying hundred thousand
by the end of by the end of 2020 yeah
you would have been absolutely crucified
you had people saying that you should
take out a mortgage on your house to buy
bitcoin you have people saying that you
leverage it yeah you should max out your
credit cards and no in november it got
up to 69 000 and that's when it started
to teeter off yeah so you just use that
as a rule so
even if you're long-term bitcoin nothing
goes up in a straight line nothing so
then what you do is you wait for panic
to add to your position so what would
panic look like if you get a guy like
michael saylor having to sell
if you stop seeing all the commercials
on cnbc
another thing that i'm you know the
bitcoin conference is here in miami as
you guys know june yeah was there yeah
so one of the things that i'm doing is
i'm trying to monitor the ticket sales
for the bitcoin conference
so let's say last year they had 15 000
in ticket sales next year if they have 5
000 okay now i'm getting interested and
if the year after that they have a
thousand now i'm really really
interested
because they you know bitcoins dead oh
no one would in their right mind would
buy cryptocurrency that's panic and
that's when you want to consider buying
again it's just like real estate in
2012. you know i retired in 2012 and i
went
you know head first into real estate and
everyone was telling me that i'm crazy
george don't you know that real estate
always goes down it never goes up in
price it's been coming down since 2006
it's the worst thing you can possibly
invest in
right when you start hearing that you
know you're on to something i mean
that's one of kind of my rules of
investing is just go ahead and tell your
friends and family members your idea
if they say oh my gosh that's a
fantastic idea how can i do that
you know that you probably want to
rethink that right but if they tell you
that you're absolutely out of your mind
that's probably going to be a winner by
the way i 100 agrees what you're saying
because it goes to speak of what you
know the what warren buffett says is
that be greedy when people are fearful
and be fearful when people are greedy
you know cnn they have what's called the
fear and greed index i don't know if you
can just google fear greed index we
covered this on pb podcast the other day
but essentially what you're saying is do
the freaking opposite of what everyone
else is telling you to do like if you're
getting an uber and your uber driver is
like yeah you know i just got some
cardano and solano and i'm buying uh i'm
gamestop and i'm doing all this it's
like
it's like what
you don't yeah or at least that's where
you can be a little fearful wait to add
to your position extreme fear this is
this is what's this is what's called by
century theater that's moving the market
right now right what emotion is driving
the market now if you looked at this in
2020 sorry maybe 2021 when after all the
printing and the quantitative easing and
the buying of bonds and all that fun
stuff
it was extreme greed
right dogecoin was worth 5721 yeah it
would have been extreme greed so what
this is telling you is short term they
may there might be a buying opportunity
but it all depends on your time horizon
100 are you trying to guess what's gonna
happen in three months or six months or
are you trying to say okay what are the
probabilities of x y z event happening
in five years ten years yes and i'm
going to go ahead and just build a
position slowly based on hysteria and
panic so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]